[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español este la primer emisión de
escala en parís del año por lo que les
deseamos evidentemente lo mejor para el
2022 y para comenzar les invitamos a
hacer un recorrido turístico por perú
país que está desarrollando una campaña
para captar más turistas no sólo de
francia sino del mundo entero para
hablar de este tema y de lo que está
haciendo pero de lo que nos ofrece en
materia turística saludamos la presencia
en nuestro estudio de rosario pajuelo
que es ni más ni menos que la directora
de promperú francia y del mundo
bienvenida rosario a esta escala en
parís
muchas gracias habilidad es un placer
tenerla con nosotros pero está
desarrollando una campaña decíamos muy
importante a nivel no sólo de francia
sino de toda europa para atraer turistas
a su país pero al mismo tiempo como todo
el resto del mundo ha sido ha sido
víctima de las consecuencias de la cob y
de cómo ha afectado esta pandemia en el
caso de su país
para el perú el turismo es el corazón de
nuestra economía y en ese momento todos
los sectores públicos privados están
comprometidos a reactivar ese sector
ciertamente el co beats golpeó muchísimo
no solamente el perú américa latina y el
mundo en un sector que da trabajo que es
inclusivo y el perú ha desarrollado
diferentes estrategias para lanzar y re
conectarnos al mundo en tres estrategias
que el gobierno y el ministerio de
comercio exterior y turismo ha lanzado
es un plan de reactivación a tres años a
tres años para recuperar los niveles que
teníamos antes de kobe donde crecimos
vigorosamente de manera sostenida
recibamos 4.4 millones de turistas por
año 4,4 millones por año si yo
actualmente cuánto recibieron en el 2020
estamos hablando no olviden porque si en
el caso por ejemplo de cusco machu
picchu en nuestra joya hemos recibido
unos 300 mil turistas para esta adicción
sin embargo nos estamos reactivando
gradualmente pero de manera segura y
sostenida hemos obtenido los seguidos de
reconocimiento los 6 grados que son
otorgados por el consejo mundial de
turismo y de viajes y turismo que
reconoce aquellos destinos turísticos
que ha mostrado no es llegar a los
estándares de seguridad y de higiene
contra el códice entonces esto es muy
importante
además a nivel interno se han
desarrollado diferentes políticas
públicas para apoyar a un sector a la
oferta turística tanto a hoteles guías
de turismo con subvenciones com
programas que promueven el empresarial
emprende turismo turismo emprende
programas para desarrollar pequeños
negocios para las microempresas decíamos
evidentemente todo el mundo ha sido
afectado por la pandemia evidentemente
hay que recordar que en el 2021 en estas
mismas épocas
parís perdón perú registraba más de 3000
muertos por día más de 3000 muertos por
día hoy ha bajado considerablemente más
del 60% de la población se encuentra la
vacunada pero que otras medidas aplica
en este caso el gobierno del presidente
castillo para asegurar que el turismo
que llega a ese país tiene las garantías
para moverse claro dentro de las normas
que están imponiendo las condiciones de
separación sanitarias de que está
implicando esta pandemia que no acaba
nunca
toda la caída de valor del sector
turismo viene aplicando protocolos de
bioseguridad de bioseguridad para dar
esa confianza para establecer la
confianza del viajero que hoy día busca
llegar a destinos sobre todo sostenibles
como el perú perú se busca ser
posicionarse como un país que dé
seguridad pero además
que desarrolle turismo comunitario y
para esto por ejemplo en el aeropuerto
jorge chávez ha instalado en lima y
principal no laboratorios para hacer los
tests costes
contra el cob y luego los hoteles
también están brindando facilidades se
requiere en todo en todo espacio público
también privado en la utilización de la
máscara génica 95 o también si no es el
caso poner doble mascarilla que es
obligatorio luego
no solamente machu picchu ha obtenido el
sello sex travel pero además muchísimos
otros reservas naturales
hay
diferentes otras ciudades en todo el
país que han de entender estos esos
sellos de
seguridad y concretamente decíamos en un
principio antes de la pandemia ustedes
reciben 4 millones de turistas tienen
alguna meta para este de 2022 rosario
tenemos metas
digamos más cualitativas porque queremos
ir creciendo gradualmente y restaurando
es pensamos que acá está esa
recuperación va a tomar unos dos años
para llegar a los 4.4 millones que
teníamos hasta antes de la pandemia
pero realmente
con francia francia tenemos una conexión
muy especial
francés el segundo país
emisor de turistas desde europa hacia el
perú pero además es el primer
país que crecía en término de turistas
porque hay una atracción hacia la más
grande civilización de américa la más
antigua con cinco mil años de caral
nuestra civilización el canal que
después de mesopotamia se ubica en
segunda la historia entonces tiene una
una atracción no solamente en el
patrimonio cultural arqueológico sino
también en la biodiversidad natural y
paisajística y el tercer gran
ingrediente es
es este el pueblo peruano reconocido por
su hospitalidad
generosidad
esa empatía que tiene con el viajero con
el turista que lo recibe no con las
manos abiertas ahora bien es verdad que
es un país maravilloso lo dice usted con
una gran cantidad de atractivos
turísticos culturales culinarios vamos a
ir hablando de todos estos temas pero
hay un tema que me parece fundamental
esta crisis ha demostrado la fragilidad
precisamente que representa para un país
que se basa en el turismo el desarrollo
de la economía es decir finalmente el
turismo es este gran sector de chimenea
blanca como se le conoce pero la
pandemia ha demostrado que finalmente es
muy frágil que ofrecen ustedes que está
planteando el gobierno del presidente
castillo para dejar de depender de lo
que es estrictamente el sector turismo
el sector turismo que yo sepa en el caso
de perú aporta lo más grande en divisas
fuera de las exportaciones tradicionales
del perú ese turismo representa el
tercer
tercera fuente de generación de divisas
el país
y un 3.8 por ciento del pib y en su país
y además
da trabajo sobre todo a cerca de un
millón y medio de peruanos de manera
directa o indirecta pero además no
solamente la parte cuantificable sino
que tiene efectos secundarios en lo que
es imagen del país en lo que es
atracción de inversiones porque las
inversiones vienen en relación a un país
que ofrece estos atractivos turísticos
así que
para diversificar no solamente queremos
seguir por supuesto
muy ligados a turismo porque es como así
como francia depende en gran medida de
su turismo también el perú pero además
también tenemos el desarrollo de las
exportaciones por ejemplo en la
diversificación de la oferta para no
solamente en productos sanos que son un
complemento al turismo porque el viajero
de hoy en día está buscando países
atractivos que le den esas experiencias
únicas experiencias en sabores en
vivencias que hoy día se hacen mucho más
importantes pues esta pandemia no hablar
de turismo hablar de perú evidentemente
es hablar de machu picchu la ciudadela
la gran ciudadela con miles de años de
existencia
para preservar este sector que sabemos
que es fundamental es muy frágil
precisamente yo quisiera como
comparación citar un caso el gobierno de
ecuador impuso medidas muy claras muy
restrictivas para la gente que visita
las islas galápagos que hace el gobierno
peruano para preservar esa la joya
arqueológica que es machu picchu hay
medidas restrictivas en este terreno por
ejemplo el santuario histórico de machu
picchu es además una de las siete
maravillas del mundo moderno y no
solamente eso sino que además ha ganado
ha obtenido el sello en la certificación
carbono neutral que hay muchísimo muy
importante porque respeta primero los
los estándares y las condiciones de ser
patrimonio de la humanidad de la unesco
este analista no entonces hay un aforo
máximo de 3.500
visitantes por día es estar nacional
estos visitó por día no entonces hay un
se ha ido aumentando gradualmente
la lista de espera para poder visitar me
imagino sí pero hay por turnos además se
han están abriéndose nuevos
accesos a la ciudadela
y el hecho de haber certificado carbono
neutral entonces hay unos programas para
reforestación alrededor de todo ese
santuario también un programa de para
los desechos sólidos y también el
reciclaje de plásticos esto es muy
importante porque al año 2050 deseamos
ser un país y sobre todo en la parte de
cusco carbono cero no que es tan
importante para la sostenibilidad
turística sepa que precisamente a partir
del próximo 16 de abril aquí en parís en
la ciudad de la arquitectura que se
encuentra en la capital francesa se va a
abrir una gran exposición precisamente
dedicada a esa maravilla que se va a
llamar ni más ni menos machu picchu el
lector es sordo y perú machu picchu y
los tesoros del perú que seguramente
servirá como aliciente para que ustedes
atraigan ese turismo que tanto desean
rosario este año tenemos efectivamente
el machu picchu y los tesoros incas no
han 190 piezas únicas que llegarán de
los museos del perú para presentar
necesiten aceite de la arquitectura de
la arquitectura parís donde invitaremos
haremos unas acciones especializados
también a la turoperación a los
turoperadores a los profesionales que
son nuestros aliados para para
promocionar nuestro destino no vamos a
tener
cuatro meses cerca hasta septiembre esta
exposición maravillosa que se presenta
en parís y no solamente esta exposición
sino que eso es una serie de acciones
que ha venido tomando el ministerio prom
perú el estado para presentarnos en la
expo dubai en este momento se desarrolla
tenemos un pabellón donde muestra la
riqueza de todas las regiones las 25
regiones del país están mostradas ahí
nuestra cultura nuestra gastronomía
acabamos de presentar un
maravilloso
nacimiento preparado por los artesanos
de huancavelica de huancavelica unas
regiones maravillosas donde está arte
manual se ha hecho visible en un momento
en la plaza de san pedro entre éstos
tenemos diferentes también acciones en
francia regresamos al salón mundial de
turismo para conectarnos con el público
con el público final además vamos a
estar presentes en las salones de
turismo tornel ahora no
nos queda mucho tiempo lamentablemente
está muy rápido nos quedan muchos temas
por tratar del aspecto culinario de otro
en todo caso esperamos tenerla
próximamente con nosotros en otra escala
en parís le agradezco rosario su
presencia yo recuerdo que usted es la
directora de promperú aquí en francia
gracias por habernos acompañado y a
ustedes les damos una próxima cita aquí
la próxima semana en otra escala en
parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]